[Music]
welcome to I'm rat and I'm link today at
the round table of them lighted a little
melodic
we are going to be taking you on a
journey associated with our book um and
we've been talking listen we've been
talking a lot about our book cuz we get
excited about the book and we're not
going to and now it's out well I mean if
you listen to this very early and it's
release it's available tomorrow but for
all intents and purposes the book of
mythicality 10 is out get it at book of
mythicality calm yeah so we're gonna be
talking about nothing that we talked
with this week we on the day of the
release on GMM we talk about the book
extensively and everything that's in the
book and lots of seekers that are
revealed in the book so we're not gonna
do that on your biscuits what we're
gonna talk about is a little bit more
in-depth behind-the-scenes process like
how did we get to this point
like Nishal idea how it evolved over
time we we always thought it would be a
great idea to to write a book I'm not to
get into it right now but I'm just
setting the premise that I had no clue
and you didn't eat it we had no clue
what it took to write a book what what I
knew the whole time I was just playing
along what goes into it and so what we
would like to do today is just take you
on a on a guided tour will be your tour
guides on what it's really like to to
write a book and make a book it's a lot
more than just writing at least for us
at least for us don't know if it's
normal
I don't not trying to normalize the book
writing process to what our experience
has been probably very abnormal but let
it let us let us guide you through it I
mean we were surprised maybe you will be
too
but speaking of tour guides I have a
little little personal update it sounds
like I'm about to say I'm going off to
be a tour guide
no I recently and if you follow me on
the Instagram read em see shout out to
read em see that's me
can't give a shout out that's just so
nice taste I shout out to myself cannot
shout
yourself out I just did twice do it
again shout out to red MC on Instagram I
know I know because I'm Magnum is
physically capable of doing this but cuz
it's not a good look I have an active
growing audience and Instagram that I
interact with doesn't mean you have to
just get up in arms you don't have to
have that I'm sorry I'm totally secure
in my lack of instagramming I'm just
saying as a friend I just don't like
being friends with people who shout
themselves out you know I have a joy
sucker
shoutout to read em see Instagram what I
did on that stop Dewey I don't do a lot
of instagramming over on the red MC
Instagram account but it's like me it's
like me coming home and it's like hey
family shout-out to link he's home it's
kind of like we can do anything we want
that's the beautiful thing we don't have
some corporate overlords that we report
to we are the corporate overlords
well I'm overloading you right now do
you walk into your house your land
daddy's home every day shoutout to dad's
home
it's so weird and not true I'm just
trying to get I want people to know that
it's just another facet if they want a
little insight and you know what I think
they can go over to read em see on
Instagram I think that you should look
into becoming a tour guy oh that might
be a good new thing for you that is
where this started you if you follow the
red MC on Instagram account you do know
that I posted for the first time ever I
did multiple pictures in a post it's one
of those things this is typically how I
am there's some sort of innovation in
social media in the likes 36 months
later I like I think I'm gonna try that
and then weeks later you tell me about
it I'm like okay yeah and so I went on a
hike with my boy and my youngest boy
Shep and I was like I'm gonna take some
pictures on this hike for posterity but
then when I got through and I started
looking through him I was like I should
post these I'm gonna post four of them
how about that give people look forget
about posterity this needs to be about
popularity exactly one of the most liked
posts ever on the read am saying
Instagram account was
the one with me and chef and then some
other oddities I found on my camping
camping trip no hiking trip up at
Switzer falls incidentally the place
that we shot the did you get me anything
seen where yeah then we fought the snake
the Nickelback monkey snake and I found
the exact spot took the picture has
changed a little bit it's a little bit
of overgrowth and maybe some rocks have
moved a little bit or maybe I didn't
find exactly the same spot oh really
no I think I did I actually looked at it
later and said yep that's it but anyway
what I did is I got I got this book I
tend to go into gift shops that have
like a little book section and I always
just feel very compelled to walk out
with a book and like Nature Center's
yeah in actually and so I actually found
one that said 100 hikes in the Angeles
Crest or whatever so basically our
Angeles National Forest right right on
the edge la you can just drive there and
right now 20 minutes or less you're in
the wilderness and I and one of the
things I've learned about myself is if I
have something that I want to do like I
would like to hike more I would like to
be more intentional about hiking mm-hmm
right I've said that too it helps me if
I take it out out to me I've said that
yeah yeah hey you yeah you're not gonna
learn anything on your Instagram though
but I have found that if I take a
tangible step like getting a book about
the hikes I'm so much more likely to
then go and do the hike hmm that's that
may be helpful for me and so I got the
book oh it would be super helpful for
you because if you took the time to
spend money on something you would back
it up with action in a heartbeat you're
not like I mean I also have like 20
other books that I've taken no action on
but you would take immediate action on
it
well I doesn't recommend this do you
think it would count if I borrowed the
book from you it wouldn't be no because
you don't attach value to borrowing
borrowing but then there's like a social
guilt of like have you read my book have
you done any of the hikes I don't do
that I'm not that kind of friend you
know if you want to do shout outs to
yourself we can do it all day what kind
of friend are you right I'm an
accommodating friend I'm an encourage
her I'm an encourage her you're a great
friend
so what I did and everything you say is
is I got this book and it had it has a
map in the back a fold-out map
waterproof and shout out to waterproof
maps and then it also has 100 hikes that
you can take in the Angeles National
Forest and so I get really I'm like how
many have you done one I was like
Shepard let's go and do a hike today cuz
Jesse was with Locke and I was like I'm
gonna have some father-son time we can
you know half an hour up into the into
the Angeles Crest you can you can be at
some awesome hiking and I like read
about this place and got super excited
about it I was like this is gonna be a
great hike and maybe we'll find like a
place that one day we can camp and then
I go there I'm like oh this is the same
place that a we filmed that video and B
me and Jesse had been on a hike before
but I was already there Switzer falls
falls you didn't have the book before I
didn't have the book now that I had the
book I was even I was more oriented to
someplace that I was already oriented to
but this is where the tour guide part
comes in because I read all about this
this is another cool thing is that I was
able to appreciate the location in a
different way because what like what
well it's a super cool place
you remember how cool it is and there's
this like you know it's very like wooded
and there's like a cool like creek that
comes through there and yeah because we
want we we shot there because we wanted
it the script said jungle like we're
ever gonna shoot in a jungle yeah and it
doesn't like a Jenelle like the most
jungle like place that you can find
there's a lot of green it doesn't look
like that to like a lot of stuff like if
you watch a lot of Power Rangers every
time they're like woods it's very
specifically like Griffith Park desert
sort of scrubby mean it's light up I
know where they shot that right well it
was all shot in Japan but I get you
bright and the American version yeah
they they shot the they shot it like the
American kids outside of the suits and
yep so anyway but there's a whole lot
first of all the hike that continues
down and goes up to unto this Ridge and
goes back into the canyon highly
recommended I told you this you should
do it with your family but I started
reading about it and it was like this
place was home to this incredible
wilderness camp that all these like
celebrities
like Ava Gardner and Clark Gable like
back in the 20s and 30s would come up
and this was like the who's who of
Hollywood with only people who can make
it up because there were Angeles Crest
Highway didn't exist at the time there
were other ways to get to the area and
this family like opened up this
incredible wilderness camp they built
like a castle up there so it's kind of
like what Ojai is now we hear like these
highfalutin celebrities like oh but it's
a week but it's different in that it's
totally in the wilderness Ojai is just a
beautiful town that has a bunch of great
houses and stuff this was like yeah he
had to take yet like get somebody to
take you up there it was very difficult
to access and then once you were up
there it was just this like nature's
paradise and of course as happens with
most things like that eventually it it's
no longer privatized it becomes part of
it like a public park or whatever now
anybody can get to it and the roads were
built but anyway I like read all this
cool information interesting information
like there was a bail that you could
ring when you were a mile from the end
of the the the trail where the waterfall
was and when you got to the the end of
the waterfall there would be a man who
had caught some trout for you and had
cooked it up fresh because he rang the
bell little tidbits like that
so I'm walking along with Shepherd and I
see these this other like two guys two
girls kind of like this group of people
walking together and they're like
stopping and they're like talking to
each other and I you know I'm not like
this I don't typically I'm introverted I
don't typically engage with people just
for nothing yeah just silently judge
them right and so I would typically just
walk by and but I was like walking I was
like hey guys you know that what yeah I
was like hey guys you know that there
used to be a bell
that you could ring and right around
here and you'd ring it and then there
would be a guy that cooked you fresh
trout when you got up to the waterfall
and they were like really I was like
yeah and there was a road that came down
here and they were like yeah there's an
old car engine right here and I was like
yeah but that was my fell down from the
road this was a like an incredible
wilderness camp started by a family in
1884 and was frequented by so
Bertie's like Clark Gable and Ava
Gardner so they pointed out that they
pointed out the motor yeah and then you
quickly redirected to what you knew no
but I but I gave you were like how did
this car get here I was like I'll tell
you how the car go you knew how the car
got there because there was a road that
came all the way in alongside the canyon
and it's like is probably you know a
hundred years old or whatever so like oh
cool and then they were like this is
surprising that yes yeah and then they
were like thanks for the information and
then I had a choice at that point I
could have just said ask for a tip or
not I could have just said you're
welcome but what I said was um I just
read it in a book about 20 minutes
before I got here I caved you folded and
I was thinking as I was talking about it
and they seemed engaged I was like I
could have been a tour guide and I
would've been a great tour guide I was
like throwing in little like little
tidbits I was making stuff up and
embellishing things oak here and there
oh you're saying that's what you would
do that's what I kind of started to do
cuz that's once you you did a very
unexpected thing and initiated a
conversation with strangers that could
enrich their lives but then I
immediately started thinking as you were
telling me what you said that like hi
bet even though he would never do this
once he did he'd be very tempted to
start making up stuff oh yeah
so by the end of it you like have
trapeze artists hanging from the the
canopy and you've got like the first
space shuttle was built here but I make
things up for the intention of
entertainment and usually the crowd
knows the crowd I'm making it up on
purpose but Shepard what a shepherd
would have been the crowd yeah I tell
you it applies all the time but no but
you would have you would have lied to
the couple and then you would have told
Shep later I made all that up right but
I think the bigger be like me one day
son the bigger point here is a
theological know-it-all I had an
opportunity to like really establish
myself like to just leave those people
thinking that you know what that guy
really knew his stuff maybe he's a tour
guide
maybe he's in nature expert yeah you can
totally bailed him is just like I'm just
a doofus who read a book 20 minutes ago
it's not too late and then I added and
the only reason I remember is because it
was 20 minutes ago like I even gave
myself I gave myself demerits for
reading comprehension even him the book
say hey guys I'm done with this
were you wearing all khaki no man strike
two
yeah I look totally normal you know what
don't be discouraged you can do this
again you're gone all khaki just like
you've always wanted you can go back out
just wait for another couple to come up
there's a hundred different hikes I
could read up on each one and then just
go hang out when people wait for people
to walk by hey guys want to know some
information about this hike you're on
yeah you could probably get tips mmm you
know what I should have done when they
said thanks for the information I should
have just stood there silent put your
hand out or throw a hat on the ground
have a hat on the ground or have like a
violin case that I just like sort of
just open up that's more that's really
really um you know it's a strong cue
that'd be good for Shepherd to learn to
they're like where's the violin oh
there's no violin proper panhandling
learned from my father in the wilderness
above Los Angeles speaking of reading
books making a panhandling panhandling
we're about to Panhandle to our book yes
I don't think that's what panhandling is
I think we're about to peddle our book
that means we want you to buy the book
of mythicality at book of mythicality
calm again it is out tomorrow and if
you're listening to this chances are
you're not listening today it came out
so it's out for you right now if you
don't want to go to book of mythicality
and order it which you can go and you
can order from basically any place you
can order books you can also go straight
to a place where you would buy a
physical book Barnes and Noble Target
Walmart it's going to be sold at all
those places if you want to get your
hands on them and your favorite local
bookstore you port your local bookstore
as well and also we did an audible.com
version of the book audio version which
is special in its own right and that it
has things that we could not do in the
book itself like we wrote a song and we
want you to sing at our funeral in the
book but we sang that song on the
audible version you can hear
wives actually read their part you can
hear mythical beasts give their
perspective and write and read their
parts even miss Locklear herself our
first grade teacher reads her portion of
the shout-out to her Instagram account
yeah if you want to first look at
exclusive book themed merchandise that
we are developing but have not yet
released but you want to scoop on that
sign up for the mythical monthly
newsletter that's mythical monthly
dot-com to get the scoop and also it's
like it's like scooping out our brains
because we put some tidbits in there as
well as members of the crew yeah
mythical monthly comm thank you for
supporting Internet tainment okay let's
get into this the process of writing our
book of mythicality
first of all we got to go back it's
probably I mean this represents a
two-year process and I knew that writing
a book would be a lot of work and that
it that it takes a lot of time and then
even once you finish it then for them to
actually put it together and make it
into something physical requires a lot
more time but I still severely
underestimated how much how much of
ourselves it was going to require well
and every time which is why it's so
meaningful to us now and every time we
received a nother book from one of our
friends in the mail this is tip this is
the way the YouTube community works
right
one of your friends whether that's grace
or Hannah or mamrie or Tyler Oakley or
whoever it might be they write a book
and they send it to you friend who's
also a youtuber and of course you know
you you as a community you're helping to
get the word out about everybody's books
you're like hey I'm reading this book I
love I love them go buy their book we're
a community that supports one another
and we're very happy to do that every
time we had one of those books in our
hands I think we we didn't even talk
about it but there was this sense that
like we know we need to do this at some
point
and but I think the reason that we
didn't is because we know the way that
we end up tossing ourselves in throwing
ourselves into things launching and
let's say we let things once we sort of
commit to them consume us and we knew
that a book would take a certain level
of commitment and so we always kind of
just push it off and said not yet not
yet because we don't want to just fart a
book out right and that was the my and a
book this size especially hardback that
is gonna be painful right whenever we do
fart it out but so but then ironically
when we finally started talking about
like in earnest like the business side
of let's get going with the book it the
thing that got us off the dime was a I'm
much more it's not ironic at all that
encapsulated idea well that's precisely
why we were willing to do it that's the
whole point of what I was saying is that
home because we thought that a book
would take all this time and energy and
personal commitment when Jen who works
for us said what if you guys thought
about writing I think there would be a
demand for like a mythical I mean a
Willet cookbook we were like great idea
and even right there it's like as a
title will it cookbook right is yeah
it's there's some humor in the title and
then it's like yeah we've been we've
invented and we will continue to invent
certain dishes within our Willet
episodes that people will actually want
to make and it's one of the things that
very much sort of you know not true
mythical beast but just people who kind
of just have some the people who know
that we have a show but don't know who's
written whose link those people know us
because of will it right so they're
right that's and that's a large there's
a large large contingent of people out
there now we were like this would appeal
to so many people great idea and it
won't take much work from us because
we're not the ones who cook the stuff
anyway so what do we know
we just gonna lend our our faces and our
brand to this thing and sort of oversee
it from a high creative standpoint and
we started to get very excited it wasn't
first this is gonna be easy for us first
it
we were very excited about the concept
and we knew that we could write things
around the recipes that would ultimately
be the value of the book that like oh
that's a that's a funny commentary on
the the different uses for cereal or the
the dynamic an essay on the dynamic of
covering something in chocolate and the
mad the magical qualities of that you
miss covering that but I definitely
wasn't thinking that I was thinking this
I'm just being completely honest this is
a way to write a book without writing a
book that's what I was excited about
would write some stuff we yeah but I was
like we don't have any time to write a
book so listen come up with the version
that requires the least writing and this
is probably the first argument we would
have and it either one of us could have
been in the other position it's like why
we can do this with it we can do this
with it and again it would explode out
of control but we we limited it we just
said okay this is the concept and then
we started talking to our people that
then make things happen because there's
a business side of this stuff to say
okay well you got to talk to the people
who make the books and you got a there's
a way to go about this and it's not just
you just don't start farting it out you
got to set up how you're gonna fart it
out and you got to find a book publisher
so we started going out to different
book publishers with this idea like
pitching this idea and we talked to
several different people several
different publishers and everyone was
you know any anytime anybody's got some
sort of following online and there seems
like there's some traction there but
publishers are gonna get excited about
it obviously but then we talked to got a
mat in minute crown which is a division
of Random House right is that correct
yeah well it's a crown archetype or
archetype yeah let's get that right I
always just say crown and we had this
conversation all the time and he and
Matt said I don't want to do it we got
rejected what he essentially said was
guys I feel like all our
member is the rejection you have what
would get us excited about this is if we
could find a way to translate some sort
of the world that you have built and he
actually just said the world that you
have built in good mythical morning and
translate that into a book because I
feel like what you guys have is so much
bigger than the fact that you eat weird
stuff and that I mean the funny thing is
is that he was the only person who
didn't just say yes exactly what you
guys want to do is a great idea and
here's why and we're gonna support you
it was like I actually think that
there's a bigger and better idea
somewhere in here and then I remember
that phone call and I this happens a lot
I was just like I know I he I know he's
right I know he's right but I don't want
him to be right because if he's right
then we're gonna take the next year of
our lives putting this book together and
we were wrong because it's two years
right yeah but he was I mean he was not
flattering us but it was flattering that
he understood the breadth of what we
were creating and what we were about as
artists I mean it it I really
appreciated the fact that he he rejected
our small idea because there was a much
better bigger idea that we didn't come
out and say on the call but we were like
well yeah we kind of knew what maybe we
did but I don't think we did it's like
yeah okay cuz after the phone call I
remember the debrief between us was like
he's right but well we'll do that
eventually but let's just do but we're
not gonna do it right now so let's do
this smaller idea this fun idea it could
be very successful idea to put it in the
context of what was going on at the time
because this was fall of 2015
so we were we knew that we wanted to we
already were thinking about buddy system
we didn't know specifically but we knew
that like 2017 was going to be the year
where we did our first big large-scale
narrative project and in buddy system
specifically being on YouTube red that
wasn't in play
at the time but we we basically knew
that was going to happen mm-hmm
we knew that was going to take a lot of
time because we had to write that and we
had to produce that of course GMM is
sort of a constantly moving train that
requires constant attention from us so
that takes up a lot of our time but we
were also you know we had moved into
this new space I've continued to expand
as a company there was just a lot of
moving parts that we were ultimately
responsible for and it just didn't seem
like the wisest thing to add a book that
would take a lot of our time because
there's only so many hours in the day
and so I think that was what we were
resistant to and I don't even really
remember well I know I know what it was
we talked ourselves into a process that
we thought would be doable and before
that I think there were a number of
trusted voices in our lives that said
you never get a second chance to write a
first book and it matters a whole lot if
if if your rationale is i'ma write this
I'm gonna I'm gonna do a little fart and
then we'll do a bigger fart later let's
drop the fart thing yeah yeah yeah it's
not sustainable yeah I don't know yeah
then the fart analogy really not your
book to a fart is right not cool at all
does it a disservice um what was I
saying first book one chance on your
first book right and so our whole
rationale of we'll get this out of the
way and then we'll get to the Big Daddy
later actually by doing it that way we
we may never get to it because we may
never earn the right to be able to do it
based on the success of the first thing
so you should throw and then I know as
we will talk about Jake more in a little
bit but I think he echoed that through
the process in terms of like what we
hold back from this book and what we
decided to put into it and he did a
great thing in in in coaxing out of us
just the mentality of when in doubt
throw it out there throw it into the
book pour pour more of ourselves into it
and don't worry there's if you want to
do a
book later worry about that later you'll
find plenty to write about we'll find ya
and he's definitely right about that but
and in those initial conversations with
Matt he kind of explained again this is
one of those things that I know that
there we're gonna be totally honest
about exactly the way the book came
together because I know that there was
that whole controversy with youtuber
that I'm not going to name you can look
it up if you want to wear it like kind
of came out that like her book was ghost
written or his book or his book was
completely ghost written and then I
don't even know if that was true but
that person had to defend themselves and
I think the impression is with a lot of
people who have any kind of following
online if you're not known for being a
writer the assumption a lot of people
have is is that okay if this is an
athlete or an actor or something like
that well they're probably got somebody
else to write the book we were very very
sensitive to that because that's not how
we do things and out of a sense of pride
and also just through the way that we
tend to work is that fashion we've got a
lot we throw a lot at what we do and so
the idea that somebody else would come
in and write something that represented
us was anything that we were interested
in but we were talked into having
somebody come in and facilitate the
process by Matt and that person is Jake
green and so if you open up the book you
see it says with Jake green and that is
very much because we wrote this book
with Jake green and what we mean by that
is that and it well unless we could talk
about that process because the first
thing that we didn't we didn't know how
much of our personal stories were going
to go into the book when we sat down and
talked about this and we're like well
let's break out this concept of
mythicality let's define what it is
because we used to be the thing that
characterizes everything that we do and
you remember the first idea we had was
well the working title before we had an
idea based on our conversations with
Inman was the good mythical book as a
play on good mythical morning and it was
just a companion to
the show but then once you try to figure
out what the format will be we talked
about it being in a cyclic and
encyclopedia of mythical of mythicality
and that was the actual title it was and
I think once yeah we had the original
we got rejected by Matt he gave us all
of his good reasons we had a great
conversation we decided okay we're gonna
do this we pitched this idea back to him
which was even which was still it was
broader in its subject matter but it was
it was still not committing all the way
personally
so it was an alphabetized compendium of
information that you know 4p it could be
[Music]
you could have an entry that would be
very heady like parallel universe
parallel universes and then right
underneath it it could say and it could
be a long essay that we've written about
parallel universes that could be
communicating Eicher and it could have
some have some learnings in it and then
right underneath it it could say have
the next P entry and it would be poot
and then to continue the fart because we
love farts and then right beside it it
would just say the only word links mom
is comfortable referring to a fart ass
and that would be the whole anyone have
a picture of my mom yeah and so the idea
was to take it was the answering the
question what is good mythical more it
really it was more what does good
mythical morning as a book well on the
show we explore things that are
fascinating to us but we also talk about
personal things so it was like this is
sort of a scaled-down chronicle baptized
organized way of exploring those things
but then and we were even talking to
Jake as we were interviewing who we were
gonna get to work with us on this thing
and you know we were bouncing so part of
us hiring him and choosing to work with
him was his take on the Encyclopaedia
idea and like his thoughtful response to
it yeah he had some skills that would
help with that but then he also had some
input that I remember let us away from
actually well doing it what it was is
that we've ought we were protective
because we always thought
that one day we were gonna write the
sort of the memoir ish type thing right
which is pretentious all in its own I
know just a couple of guys I met YouTube
videos why do I need why don't you guys
know you need to have a memoir book
whatever we knew that you know with the
shared friendship and 30-plus years of
history together there's there's
something there there's a lot to talk
about but I think we always saw that
being and more of just a straight
text-heavy memoir presentation and so we
were trying to keep some of the stories
and keep some of the history hold it
back and when he was like guys what you
have in good mythical morning and
mythical entertainment all this it flows
out of who you guys are personally in
your personal history so you really
can't start talking about this unless
you break it open and just let
yourselves be in this book and again it
was one of those things where it's just
like I know he's right but I don't want
him to be right I know he's right but I
don't want him to be right mm-hmm and so
then okay and just as a side note here
you know I'm so appreciative to everyone
who helped with the book but you you
already see how important it is to
choose the right people to trust and and
to invite input you know with with when
sometimes when people like 'man or Jake
or in your ear case mythical beast I'm
talking directly to you now if you if
you trust someone and then they tell you
something that is not exactly what you
want to hear well your ears should perk
up a little bit and that's the type of
people that you need in your life
not only on a creative front right and
so when he was talking about that I
remember thinking well how are we gonna
do this in a way that won't require oh
and let me just say by this point this
was spring of 2016 we were in the middle
of writing buddy system getting ready to
produce it at the schedule at Penn put
together and we're still meeting with
Jake to develop this idea and talk about
it and of course we're always neck deep
in good mythical morning
oh yeah and not to mention GMM is
happening constantly five days a week
and we were doing ear biscuits I know I
think we know we're taking a break we've
had so gone by the wayside you
understand why we took a long break from
ear biscuits now I mean that was the
one thing that we made an executive
decision not it wasn't because we go to
the beach in Disneyworld every other day
it's because we don't have any time so
we had to figure out a system to to get
to contribute to our book ah and and how
much and Jake suggested well why don't
we sit down in this room that we're
sitting in right now at the round table
of dim lighting and he says why don't we
just have conversations about
mythicality and some of the stories that
you guys have had and and I'm just gonna
take notes and I didn't know exactly
what that meant cuz I think there was a
part of us even though we really wanted
to have a lot of control over this
because we were so busy and stressed out
at the time that all these conversations
had happened and they would happen and
be like I'm gonna be here today for
three hours we got to get this done and
it was in between a lot of other things
I think I was secretly hoping that we
could just sit down and have these
conversations and these anecdotes and
that he would take it and basically
write it down and then we would just
edit it I was secretly hoping that
that's what would happen and I know
that's how a lot of like celebrity books
are written yeah and I was very
self-conscious about that but we're so
busy I was thinking that that might be
how it came together if that was the
only way to make it happen
we became more open to it which then I
think to double back on what you're
saying about the indictment of books
that are ghosts written it's it's not
it seems horrible from the from the
outside but there's a scenario where you
can where it's totally your story but
then somebody's just literally typing it
on a page and making it no sense from a
in an in a written form and so it's not
as ugly I think people make it out to go
yeah yeah because we became open
actually that's collaboration that's not
ghost writing is more just like I'm just
gonna you know I've done some research
about you not gonna write your book
that's the perfect ghost writing
situation the ideal goes write a
situation but in that maybe is a little
ugly but that didn't happen with us no
and what ended up happening as it was us
talking through these stories and then
when we sat back down and looked at the
notes he had made notes he had not
written you know paragraphs he had made
notes of light you guys talked about
this she talked about this she talked
about this
having he was able it out there and then
having it presented back to us was when
we began to see it materialized in a way
that's like okay well now we've got to
take those notes and those stories and
we've got to pick the one that we think
best illustrates this aspect of
mythicality and so it was a little bit
of a myth mix-and-match some things
really presented themselves we're like
well we know we want to have something
about our wives in there our wives we
feel like there were some very mythical
things that we did in the process of
convincing our wives to marry us and
wouldn't it be cool if we kind of told
those stories but then let them have
their perspective and they're really
honest say and actually write in that
chapter of what they thought and and so
some of the things kind of presented
themselves and eventually we just found
ourselves sitting down and so all that
there's there's two different parts of
the book there's every chapter put on
before you get to that okay because I
find it interesting in that process I
mean the first meeting we had with Jake
and we were talking about what we wanted
our book to be at that point I believe
we knew we wanted to describe
mythicality like we started talking
about that as a term yeah and so then it
was okay so then there's different
aspects of that that are different
chapters but let's just have a
preliminary discussion about what those
different things may be a good example
being I love lives and then the wild
hare idea to let our wives actually
contribute and say it from their
perspective that was very exciting
because it was a great way to involve
our wives when we've they we've all
collectively said well they don't want
to be in videos and that's fine so this
is like really exciting I remember we we
talked about a chapter called eat
something that scares you very early
because the whole food Willet thing was
still on the forefront of our minds from
the very first seed of the book but then
it's you know conceivably you and I
could have sat down here like we're
doing right now and just talk to each
other but I don't think it it would ever
have happened I mean we have lots of
conversations that just the two of us
but
there's something about there being an
audience there being you listening right
now that that motivates the I mean the
quality of our conversation
the contain a lot of other things but so
with Jake being there and him being very
skilled it as a listener and being above
synthesize everything we were saying
that it was extremely valuable but he
was also very valuable as an audience
you know we recorded all of it because I
felt like okay this may turn out to be
something special so I just I want to
record this whole thing and then he
could but he also has to record it so
instead of just taking notes he could
listen back to it so it was like a
podcast for one person and your biscuit
just for Jake greening some of them were
six hours long yeah but there's no way
you and I would have we would have
gotten you know we got we got frustrated
we got off-topic you know as a as a
conversation project manager he did
something that I didn't appreciate
I couldn't have appreciated ahead of
time and he also took a look at
everything that we've done in our
content and came back and pitched
chapter ideas
mm-hm he's like this seems like an
aspect of mythicality that you guys have
just naturally manifested and sometimes
it takes people kind of a third party
looking at that and he's like you know
talk to me about that are there stories
that contribute to that now for example
this isn't exactly perfectly they all
came together different but you take the
second chapter which is called get lost
so we had this thing that we did all the
time when we were kids which is we would
just get on our bikes and we would ride
in one direction and we would just go
until we found something and there was
this sense of exploration in the sense
of risk in the sense of open-endedness
to the things that we were doing and
there was a it was kind of a game
formatting too and then we started
realizing that this tendency that we
actually started to do together as as
kids was something that applied to our
career and we didn't even know it that
our entire career has been characterized
not by having as a very specific plan
our specific goals but has been
characterized by heading in a certain
direction with intention and then sort
of figuring it out as we go along and
taking and being ready to discover
things and to take risks embrace the
unknown structure that into your life so
so the whole chapter became about that
concept and the stories that support it
yeah kind of backing into some
principles that led to the success we've
experienced is something that we
discovered and then we said oh okay
so getting lost is an aspect of
mythicality and calling it get lost is a
fun title for a chapter we knew we
didn't want to we didn't want to format
it as an advice book we ended up calling
it a field guide that was that was his
advice advice ish as we were willing to
get which is still is pretty it we wish
I mean there's a self-help nature to our
book but we didn't want it to be like
totally self-help we want to be just as
entertaining but yeah I mean a lot of
that came out of us just telling stories
and not knowing exactly what the
application was so I think we learned
what we learned well you like relearned
it by telling the stories and then
saying okay and then at other times Jake
would say that's it I love the story you
told about remember that one I'm trying
to remember the thing he came back at
one time and he was like the story I
think it was Chris barefoot we told a
story about hitchhiking I was in this
chapter he doesn't get lost
and um hitchhiking after discovering
Chris Barefoot's house and he got such a
kick out of the guys name being Chris
barefoot he was like this has to be in
your book right and so it like really
motivated us to make that work and
there's that there are some stories a
bunch of stories that didn't make it in
but sometimes the stories are so good
that we build a chapter around it I
think that that may have been one of
those cases trying to think of another
example what you've got you know conduct
a weird experiment which is based on a
there's a story there we've never told
yeah that's that's a smoke story well in
that also that in that same chapter we
talk about the the laws that we broke
some of the only laws that we broke in
in high school right and because it was
the result of an experiment that we did
together so science can justify lots of
things and then of course there were
because this is a first and foremost
it's it's a book that's supposed to it's
supposed to make you laugh right we want
you to to to read this book and to be
entertained by it and to laugh we want
you to learn at the same time and be
challenged to add more mythicality to
your life but because we wanted it to be
funny there are some chapters that are
very much exclusively funny I would say
chapter 13 visit the future the the
chapter that was written from the Year
2075 where we imagined ourselves no we
did that okay yeah well these are the
air biscuit ears man and we can you know
you're gonna admit that we didn't
actually I'm gonna miss it we didn't
really travel from the future
that was a comedic device I hope that
doesn't disappoint you we did we really
haven't figured out time travel and but
as if we did figure out time travel and
come from the Year 2075 we wrote that
entire chapter and that chapter in us
coming up with the what what's gonna go
down in our friendship in the next fifty
years and the different ups and downs of
the show and our friendship and the
different diversity it's this craziest
it's like the most
Rick and Morty ish that we've that we've
gotten in terms of how random and I mean
that that chapter to the stake when we
read that chapter for the audible book
we both had laugh attacks reading it
because it was shout out to us
that was funny things like yeah yeah
especially when you separate yourself
from it like when you've written it and
then you've step back but I do want to
talk about so jig did more than that
Jake did more than help organize the
ideas and and he was more than a
sounding board because write the book
has two parts to it
you know first of all a lot of it is
memoir and archives so you've got these
stories that from our shared experience
are shared
friendship and then all the like
archival photos and different tidbits
and we we broke open so much archival
stuff from your books to photos to notes
to book reports and all that goes in
there to help support the stories but
then the other part of the book is what
the unsexy term that we use as we were
developing the book with supplemental
material and that was because we want
this book to be super entertaining what
can we do when we okay say the get lost
chapter as an example if we're gonna
tell this story about getting lost when
we were kids and then we're gonna talk
about how that applies to our to our
career then what can we do to add to
that to supplement that to give you some
just content that you can just hey just
turn to a page and enjoy this and I
think that yeah let's step through those
I mean first of all there's a there's an
entire spread dedicated to an
inspirational poster that we wrote in
the that we just it was just an
offhanded phrase that we said in the
chapter and then you made a joke about
it being an inspirational poster so then
and so that's we decided to actually
make that but then after that is when
you get into these supplemental sections
yeah and so you know I don't know
exactly what the breakdown is I'm sure
we could go back into the notes and
figure out who pitched what and and but
Jake did pitch a lot of these things
like the best and worst places to get
lost and so without a car or a bike
which is how we would get lost right and
so you've got these different
environments or these different modes of
transportation if you're on this
particular mode of transportation this
would be a great place to get lost right
like your horrible place the best and
worst place to get lost on rollerblades
scooter a jet pack a Segway a yak and a
motorcycle sidecar so Jake was very
instrumental in pitching some of those
things and then helping to develop some
of them like like let's come up with the
perfect amalgamation of beasts to create
the perfect mythical beast that never
gets lost yeah so basically taking every
animal that has some form of
echolocation or some super sense of
smell that helps them know exactly where
they're at could we if CRISPR was
available to us to use could we create
an
and so we've got that animal that
animals created and and broke it down
and drawn in the book of mythicality and
it is called the well official yes it is
and there's other things just in that
chapter but I mean and you go back to
chapter one laughs with a friend
so we collaboratively came up with hey
let's let's highlight the biggest laughs
we ever had together on good mythical
morning and then we created like a
shrine to those those moments but then
we said okay let's make a let's make a
test a laughter compatibility test to
see if you have any business being
friends with somebody yes are you and a
friend can take this test and see how
many of your answers match to see if
you've got the same sense of humor which
we think is a pretty important part of
friendship so it was again it was very
important for us to like use our stories
as a jumping-off point for us to have
engaging content at the end of the
chapters I thought we came up with a
better word than supplemental but it
doesn't matter but all that let me just
say that all that was completed months
and months ago like the writing for all
those particular pieces I don't know
what like months and months ago that was
done and then we were like okay so how
are we gonna make you tell me the
writing for the the words for the whole
book not just supplemental you tell not
now the writing was done and then the
next phase this has to be this has to be
on a physical page this has to look like
something and we know how particular we
are about aesthetics and how he wants
things to look and how we want this to
be unique and we want every page to have
character and so that began the very
long and arduous process of coming up
with the physical aesthetic presentation
of every concept especially the
supplemental things which were all
totally unique and it was like
reinventing the wheel and starting from
scratch on every single concept yeah
from a from a visual conceptual
standpoint so I mean yeah we we had
piles of archival stuff notebooks
pictures all this stuff that like Ali
went through and
scanned and then goes into the book but
then in the supplemental section it's
like well what is the well efficient all
look like well we need to illustrate
that we need an illustrator we need to
pick the right illustrator that does
wild little drawing anatomical wildlife
drawings and we want it to look like you
know when when Darwin went off in the
yeah Beagle and he came back and he had
drawing yes it's plants and stuff and he
had taken these notes can we make that
drawing of the wellif it you know it
looked like a biologist had just gone
off and found it and drawn it and then
made notes about it so that's what that
page looks like so we we didn't draw any
of this because well I did I drew the
map of our of our hometown and like
where we lived in our secret meeting
places so there's a there's a hand-drawn
map of Buies Creek and like we hand
wrote some stuff but there's a like but
there is a whole bunch I mean we might
have used between handwriting artists
and illustrators we might have used ten
different ones and the whole team at
crown that oversaw the visual aspect of
this and Feldman here on our team
helping to conceptualize everything
every it it was such a team effort to to
achieve the goal of you turn to any page
and it's a suprise what it looks like is
a surprise and and very purposeful
because I yeah because what I'll say is
okay like I'm looking at the embracing
maturity chapter where we talk about you
know there needs to be a part of you
that never completely grows up and so
we've got twenty ways to embrace in
maturity like a checklist and it
literally has a cut out and is based
very much on the Garbage Pail Kids cards
right so right yeah if you look at the
back of like a Garbage Pail Kids card it
has it has like a certain kind of text
and we tried to yeah obviously it's not
completely ripped off but it's like it's
inspired by the feeling that you got
when you looked at a Garbage Pail Kids
card on the next page we have an idea
for a ridiculous television show which
is based on a story that we
hell my dad show being my dad's favorite
show and in when we were telling this
story being Matlock we talked about
Matlock quite a lot you're gonna learn a
lot about Matlock but then we talk about
what is a modern-day version of Matlock
so we have like a TV guys which is like
a parody of a TV Guide to write up for a
show and that page looks like the old
school TV Guide and then the very next
page is just an ad that you would see in
a magazine but it's like an old school
ad that would have been around at the
time where we actually played this
ridiculous game that we talked about in
the chapter and so I don't know how many
man-hours went into each one of these
things but I don't know we're just I
hope I hope we sell some books I'll put
it to you that way I don't know but I
think we both have this sense of like
were the things that we like to consume
like the idea that like this page it was
not an afterthought this page was not
after all this page is very purposeful
in everything there's so few experiences
but there's for me being the age I am
this may not be true for everybody but
for me I feel like there's a lot fewer
experiences like that where I can buy
something physical and it's a physical
experience I
I remember the Pearl Pearl Jam album
Vitalogy I think that's how you say it
Vitalogy and it was do you remember the
the liner notes it was it you would take
it out and it was a whole book and it
was and it looked like your Tomek Darin
Darwin's drawings and this was um it was
so detailed it was like a it was a mini
booklet that had I don't know it could
have had 30 pages in it and they were it
was all like anatomical sketches and
like phrenology and all the different I
never I didn't know anything about
phrenology and all of a sudden it's like
what is what are they mapping to the
brain here and it was just so weird and
so detailed really ahead I mean it
seemed like I had nothing to do with
their music to me I was like man their
musics okay but this book
awesome right and it was you know you
could sit with it and sit with Rita and
experiences while listening to the music
and it became a palpable experience for
you that I mean doesn't happen with
music that much anymore right I mean
like this we talked about this on the
Gmail gmm episode where we talked about
the book like the creative confrontation
so we've got a whole chapter called pick
a fight where we talk about the fight
that we had some of you know about the
physical fight that we got into that was
captured on GMM we talked about the
calls in the aftermath of that but then
we talked about some fights that we've
had with other people and like the way
that we approach conflict and how we
want to change the way we do that and so
then one of the supplemental sections in
that chapter it's called creative
confrontations and it is outlining ways
to basically settle a dispute have a
confrontation have a conflict with
somebody that isn't fighting and so all
these are formatted like old-school
Nintendo games and every single it's
just like the in Feldman was very
helpful with with this to Mike Feldman
our brand strategist who's he's really
into all this retro stuff too in his
near our age and so can we kind of pull
in a lot of light 80's and 90's
references but like every one of these
video games was thought to the degree
that you would design a video game cover
this is just two pages but there are 10
different video games that were designed
and described again just trying to paint
the whole mythical picture of how every
single thing came together for this and
rounds and rounds of notes and
conversations to get it to this final
point where I don't know if you list it
out in this one Nintendo spread the
people involved some way it would
probably be almost everybody we
acknowledged in the back of the book you
know it's kind of crazy how how that
works and then we got to a point where
okay it always comes down to the wire
but we've we got the word now we've got
the visuals it's all there we've done
the photo shoot for the cover and
the the places inside where we needed
new photos and then you're just waiting
you're waiting for it to come in a box
right and it's interesting because I
wasn't here when it came in a box and I
walked in to the office our office and I
was I think I came from buddy system
post and I was kind of worked up about
something or overwhelmed about something
and so then I come in and like I
immediately trying to get your input on
something that I'm concerned about and
we're in the middle of this heated
creative conversation and then I happen
to glance down and I see the book I'm
like and you had seen the we've had what
we call bound galley which is a is a
paperback version of the book that is
just you know the cover looks exactly
the same but the inside is black and
white and it has typos in it son
corrected proof and it's soft right and
so you got a soft cover and then this
course is the hard cover and so at first
I thought that was the same thing cuz
I've had it on my desk for weeks and
then in the in in like mid rant I'm like
that's a hard cover it's hard and I'm
picking up I'm like it's it just changed
everything and it became the moment that
you can only have one switch is the
first moment you hold you little baby in
your arms and you could have prepared me
a little better you were like yeah I've
already seen it I'm like God
I've been sitting with it all day man
the final chapter you could have texted
me a picture you could have you could
have giving me a shout-out to your
Instagram one of the final chapters is
called stop and celebrate where we come
clean about the fact that we have
difficulty stopping at any point in
celebrating life's little victories or
moments of success the huge things we
kind of institutionalized well I'm not
going to tell you the chapter you can
read it marriage death things we also
talked about in the book death yeah well
yeah you had you know it's like this is
what you do when you die right you have
a funeral you you commemorate you stop
and you celebrate a life
you do that when you get married you do
you remember when birthdays right but
there's no specific established thing
that you do to celebrate when you have a
book now we talk about what we what that
is for us in the book so I'm not gonna
give that away right and we talked about
our our habit of falling short of being
appreciative of those little moments
which should be celebrated but I think
that in one sense this conversation is
part of that for us it's like reflecting
on what a huge process this has been and
all the people that we've mentioned and
haven't mentioned that made this thing a
reality and it's like you know what and
now here it is and we want to share it
with you and but it's done you can't
edit it anymore but you can physically
hold it it's different than a lot of
most everything else that we do this is
part of our moment of stopping and
celebrating and saying you know what
it's done I'm glad we did it yeah and
now let's go do the thing that we said
we were gonna do in the book and we
probably need to video ourselves doing
that yes as proof that's a good point so
we'll do that we have our special way
that we're gonna stop and celebrate you
can read it in the book well we'll
probably share it with you in a video
form afterward but for now we invite you
to be a part of the experience and thank
you to those of you who are actually in
the book you know there are a number of
collections of things not things some
things that you guys have sent us but
also we specifically reached out a lot
of people didn't even know why we were
doing this and we couldn't say it was
for the book because it was so long ago
but we wanted stories about your pets
and we wanted stories about your
inventions inventions and then some of
your fan art and that kind of thing and
so there were some very special mythical
beasts out there who contributed to the
to the book and those there spreads
exist in the book and I would say beyond
that
there are many of you and collectively
all of you made this book possible you
know this I mean so I but it but it you
shouldn't go without saying again that
like we could never make this book
without your support and you being a
part of this community that that watches
and engages in the stuff that we create
and but it goes further than that I
think it's clear it will be clear when
you read the book that you you know you
shaped our lives to the point that the
stories that we tell and the
perspectives that we have and share in
the book are shaped by the conversations
that we have with you through our
content the concept of mythicality
itself absolutely is something that not
only did you guys name yourselves the
mythical beasts mm-hmm which was based
on a story that we had but it was you
guys taking the ball across the finish
line and naming yourself the mythical
beast which then turned into this whole
mythical Enterprise and naming
everything mythical and calling this the
book of mythicality
but the very definition of mythicality
while it's rooted in something that
existed in our friendship and in a way
we did we created things the whole time
we were doing all that stuff a for an
audience and be in the context of the
greater community of mythical beasts so
this book is just as much what you guys
have contributed to us as it is
something that we want to contribute to
you so yeah your fingerprints are all
over it so we're gonna give each of you
a book if you for free for it oh no
that's that's correct your if you pay
for it we will give ya book of
mythicality calm all bookstores places
you can physically buy it remember the
audio version audible.com and then
mythical monthly com where you can see
the book related merch that's gonna come
out around this and you know if you've
listened this far you've already you've
already ordered a book right so I do
want to encourage you to think about the
the people in your life that you might
want to gift a book to because I don't
think they need to know who we are in
order
to really appreciate and a lot of this
to resonate with them this could
actually be it serve as a good
introduction you like you know those
stupid idiots that I I send you their
videos sometimes well there are more
than just stupid idiots who who eat
weird stuff on the internet take a look
at this book I think you connect with it
if you're a parent I would definitely
say buy it for your for your kid I look
forward to our children reading it and
discussing it in like an Oprah group
setting together the Oprah book club
yeah and if Oprah if you're listening
boy what we wouldn't get I mean we would
probably give a lot maybe a body part
for you to make this a your book club
book of the month but lots of picture
probably asking too much I don't know if
that's a requirement but there's lots of
good illustrations and pictures in it
lots of pictures Oprah book club now you
like pictures all right and get the get
the audio version too because it's it's
for your ears yes not unlike this I hope
you've enjoyed it thank you for letting
us weasel in and weasel into it and
share this experience of making a book
ultimately this we were concerned about
talking about our book for this whole
time and we we literally discuss should
we do this because we didn't want it to
seem like a big sales podcast but
hopefully you see our heart behind just
sharing the experience of doing this
thing and you don't hold it against us
this we will talk with you next week
[Music]